I'm 28 years old now I manage a few
businesses Transportation uh in the US
and uh uh I'm pretty you know
financially stable um and I've been I
would say spinning plates since I was
pretty much 17 till now and uh I'm in a
a specific uh uh
predicament uh I'm with this uh
now she's a she is a 21-year-old
Vietnamese uh international student
that's studying here uh in
America um and I've been with her for 14
months now and I'll be honest she's
been really good like I went through
your red flags a million times trying to
find something you know the only one
thing that I would I I don't know if
it's a red flag but anytime we're
together she's like playfully like
biting me or pinching me or things like
that you know some I feel like some
girls do that like playfully but I don't
know if that's considered violent or or
hisy fit or something like that but
besides that she's been you know really
really good um my my problem um long
story short my Oney year anniversary I
gave her a gift called like the love
book or it's like a 100 pages of our you
know our dates and our experiences and
and you know the love book yeah I is
that what it's
called yeah you can like customize it
you know it's like you by Lenor
candell I no no you can customize it's
called love book you can customize like
the characters and each page and you
know things like that okay yeah so she
loved loved it a lot every page I put I
printed a picture of us on a date and
you know we went out to Beach and we did
a bunch we had we had an amazing year
let's just put it that way okay now the
problem is her mom is this the love book
is this what you're talking about this
thing here correct yes correct okay um
long story show so her mom saw this book
after I gave it to her like after two
three days and
her mom
realized that I did care about her a lot
you know I protect her you know and do
love her and when she realized that when
she got home that day her mom almost
immediately asked her when are you going
to marry
himh and I went out to dinner with her
parents her family her sister her
parents friends they don't know much
English but you know the whole whole
conversation is around you know us
getting married and and uh you've known
her for how long a year and a half a
year and two months now okay and she's
how old 21 yeah she she yeah she turned
21 yes and your age again you said
you're 28 28 correct okay so what's the
question here what's the ask so her
family's been hounding her to get
married for very specific specific
reasons it's one to get citizenship and
two to uh
establish themselves as a citizen in in
America and to potentially start
business now her family is very well off
I would say very well off they her
parents own a uh fish Distribution
Company back in Vietnam so I could only
assume that that they're doing well her
mother
sorry did you say that they both live
here the parents both live here yes
correct so who's running the business in
Vietnam will they while they both live
here uh they travel back and forth so
they they have people working their
other family members and they come visit
her their two daughters here in America
and they go back and forth every two
three months or every oh sorry every
three to four months uh now they want to
speed up the process of their daughter
getting citizensh ship and in turn get
me getting married to her and they were
even willing to pay for the prenuptial
agreement the marriage the whole nine
yards for me to marry into the family I
already protected that's the way it's
generally been around the world by the
way is the bride's family pays for
that yeah uh they're very traditional
she is very traditional you know she was
willing to pay even out of her pocket
for like lawyers and things like that in
for like the whole nine yards and you
know and they were even willing to
potentially put their assets half into
my name as well just to quote
unquote legitimize the marriage and she
they would use like our history the past
year and two months as you know for the
citizen paperwork and and you know
things like that the whole I they even
talked to a we even talked to a uh
immigration attorney about all this
stuff they said yes yes yes everything
should work out in about a year and a
half from now
so technically speaking I don't have
anything to lose and I know with your
book you know smart men don't marry and
all my assess is protected I I put it in
trust I have my property one of my main
property homesteaded I have everything
protected with the prenuptial and she's
willing to change her name and all of
these things and I keep reading back
like any red flags any things you know
besides her you know small hissy face
and her biting me from time to time
playfully besides that you know I'm just
like I don't know okay Ryan we got to
get moving along because I got a lot of
people waiting to hop in so let's get to
the question here so what's the question
you want me to co-sign this marriage
I I know you're GNA say no but if you
were in my shoes would what would you do
well look I'm not in your shoes I'm much
older than you and I've already been
married and I don't have any reason to
get married you don't need to get
married to have children do you want to
have children uh yeah it was yeah it was
part of the conversation yeah okay so
she's looking for marriage to get
citizenship like you understand that
right correct yeah 100% yes like
this is her main driver if it's not you
she'll find another guy that will marry
her and get her citizenship yeah yeah
okay yeah so you've only known her for a
year and two months you said
correct I I would give it a good year
and a half to two years minimum before
you even entertain the conversation I
would actually push it back two years I
would I would give it a couple years to
see what she's made of see what her
family's really like how much time have
you spent with her family a lot I would
say four occasions I went I went to
their uh Thanksgiving dinner and I did
have the same conversation with them uh
you know these things take time I would
suggest two years I even told them this
and they agreed with me they didn't the
main focus the main reason they were
keep pounding her to get married she
doesn't even particularly want to at
this moment but they were keep you know
forcing her to you know
let me ask a question on your oneye
anniversary you bought her the love book
what what did she get
you um she got me like two cakes
balloons she got me uh what you call it
she got me a new wallet she got me like
oh so she she periodically gave me a lot
of gifts throughout the time one time we
we were uh we we work out from time to
time
and I had these like old shoes you know
and she was like oh she's like what's
your shoe size I'm like 11 she you
didn't I did not think much of it two
days later she got me brand new adid uh
uh gym like okay she like does she have
genuine burning desire for you I would
say yes you've read my book right yes
yes so as I describe in the book right
there's women that are enthusiastic for
you like they're promoters they're
indifferent or they're Det actors you're
saying that she's a promoter yes 100%
without any question she wants to spend
time with me more often than I could
give her you know and anytime I can't
spend time with her you know she get a
hissy fit but besides that you know she
Lo every time we're together I literally
just like dropped her off earlier too
and you know we're kissing making out
and she wanted to spend more time look
man like she sounds like a genuinely
nice person but you've only known her
for a year and a bit yeah slow it down
turn off the afterburners let's see what
she's like at the two-year Mark then if
you still feel the feel the need to put
a ring on her finger and you know get
married do that I mean um I don't know
if there's any other way for to get
citizenship aside from that but that
seems like the easiest most convenient
way to do it yeah yeah so yeah yeah she
had uh so apparently she has a fouryear
sponsorship period as an international
student how long has she been here she
been here since
17 okay and but but she still have three
and a half years from to from now how
many years was she in the States before
you met
her two so for two years yeah she was
here before you had met her do you have
any idea what her Notch count might be
I was her first you're her first yeah
okay my friend you have uh you have a
good candidate here for a long-term
relationship or if you want to wife her
up that hey you know you want to take on
the risk that's entirely up to you but I
would wait a couple years two years year
and a half to two years minimum year and
a half to two years before you even have
the conversation you know put it off a
little bit say hey look you know Mr Mrs
uh fish factory from Vietnam I really
dig your daughter's Vibe we have a good
time uh uh you know I've got this going
on she's got that going on this is a
bridge that we can cross you know in the
future but not right now we got too much
stuff happening and then just watch how
she behaves watch how the family behaves
spend time with them because keep in
mind you're gonna like you're going to
be inviting not just her into your life
but her family into your life as well
yeah her family really like me like when
I say like me like the first you've only
met them four times right like you've
only been with them on four occasions
spend yeah spend four days straight with
them see if you guys all still get along
real well yeah um right because there's
cultural differences there too oh yeah I
could tell at that point I felt like you
know her parents were treating her like
like a property to use you know yeah
like like a traditional you know but
that's the way it is in those cultures
are right so just slow it down see what
she's made of see if that's what you
want to do not because she wants it
because she wants citizenship see if
that's what you want to do yeah right
once You' sust her out and you know you
sust her family out and see if it goes
well for you okay so after a two the
twoyear or maybe threee Mark and
everything
still twoyear vetting period is more
than sufficient to see what she's made
out
of what what in your opinion are there
any risks at that point after marriage
yeah all the risks that I talked about
in the chapter of my book about why
smart men don't get married when you get
married you expose yourself to all those
risks unnecessarily Ryan every single
divorce lawyer that I know will never
ever get married and even if they have
been married in the past they'll never
get married again in the future right
especially in a place where it's hostile
towards men right um You might want to
go to the uh National Parents what's it
called there there's a report card
that's online what state do you live
in uh I rather not say but I I live in
the US okay okay so you can look up the
information for yourself then but
there's a report card I think it's
called The National Parents organization
or something to that regard but it's a
grading system where they evaluate the
states based on how friendly they are to
fathers in divorce the state I am yeah I
checked that the state I am in is very
uh uh give more rights to fathers I
would I would be in one of the top two
states like not even the top 10 like be
in the top two states so if that's what
you want to do then prepare yourself set
up for it live in that state make sure
you get to know her and her family real
well make sure that the only reason why
you're doing it is because it's it's for
you because it's cultural for you it's
religious for you because you want to
have children because you want to bring
up kids that way sort of thing not for
her not for her citizenship you
understand yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out